on the bump for new york it is 34 year
old ready
corey kluber who signed a one-year 11
million dollar deal
with new york in the off season and here
is one of two left-hand hitters only
three lefty-hitters on the entire team
this is kevin biggio he also was 0 for 5
on opening day [ __ ] individual was a
called strike so it's 0-2
now with the runner at second as biggio
pops it up
shallow left field and a long run coming
in and unable to make the catch is
frazier
now simeon couldn't go anywhere assuming
the ball would have been caught but
frazier unable to make the play
and the batter will be beau bashette
beau coming off an 0-4 game on thursday
grounded left side there's one on the
first
it's a double play runner a third and
two down for the blue jays
as one of the hitting stars of thursday
for the jays t
oscar hernandez gets his first look at
kluber
here is the 3-2 struck him out swinging
slider
so clibber pits through a lot of
problems no runs
two hits and one left and now the end of
a half inning
toronto nothing yankees are coming about
on the hill for toronto it's 31 year old
right-hander ross stripling in his
second year with the team
tripling made five appearances and two
starts for toronto last season
judge at second stanton's at first
torres at the plate gleber one for four
on opening day with a walk also scored a
run
1-1 on the way and a fastball
sent into shallow center field randall
grichik is there
and makes the catch and the inning is
over stripling gets out of it as the
yankees leave a couple of men on
well here is the mayhew and lemay who is
now on the
season over five so it wouldn't be
surprising
if he got a hit you know the mayhew and
if he does it could score two runs
who lead at second and third with two
out
chop slowly third base could be a tough
play the throw to first
not in time pulled him off the bag one
scores and the yankees have the lead
one-nothing
so now first and third as frazier moved
to third and here is
aaron judge who blistered a single the
left in the first inning
here is the 1-0 hit on the ground as
short
and bish beshett fumbles it throws the
first end time
to end the inning
yankees play bgo to pull three
infielders on the right side
jansen the runner at third let's see if
simeon is on the move
he is running and the 3-2 there
for strike three called simeon steal
second
and the throw bounces into center field
jansen will score simeon to third and
the game is tied
simeon is at third with two down in what
is now one one time here's bo buchet
here's the 2-2 strike three fastball
so actually he struck out the side but
when you strike out of the side and you
walk two you're throwing a lot of
pitches
one run unearned on
no hits one error and one left
now at the end of two and a half we're
tied at
one big spot in this game early fourth
inning
bases loaded one one game two outs
kluber against jansen and janssen hits a
ground ball to short
gleber throws to second for the force
kluber pitches
in and out of trouble so the force out
goes
6-4 no runs two hits
three left and at the end of three and a
half
we're tied at one here is sanchez to
lead it off
the 2-2 swung on and drill to deep left
that ball is high
it is far it is gone
the kraken cracks one he hits a line
drive
for a second home run of the year in the
left field seats
it gives the yankees a 2-1 lead oh that
gary is scary so he's off to
a terrific start in this cold weather
hitting two bombs
so the bases are loaded and here's aaron
hicks
bases loaded and one out pitch is hit on
the ground toward the middle
and knocked down everyone's going to be
safe
it was knocked down in the infield
scoring
is frasier everyone else moves up 90
feet
and the yankees take a 3-1 lead on the
ruby single by hicks
no two don't that'll bring up gleiber
torres
has been throwing strippling is out of
the game already for the blue jays so
there's going to be heavy-duty work from
both bullpens
here this afternoon as is so often the
case these days one
two and a swing and a miss chatwood
against torres
big big out there for chatwood the
yankees get a couple though
and do lead three to one at the end of
four
top of the order for the blue jays
marcus simeon one two pitch
on the way from kluber and simeon turns
on it hits a fly ball
deep left field it is gone
got a fastball in and yanked it down the
left field line for his first home run
as a blue jay
marcus simeon who has great power homers
and it's now a 3-2 game
so a rudder at second and two down with
the yankees up 3-2 in the bottom of the
fifth
and that gets a dangerous hitter in
clint frazier to the plate frazier has
doubled and walked already today
the 01. there's the slider and a little
one hopper
out to simeon throw to first in time
frazier and the yankees retired leading
a man on
and jonathan lawyers ago will face
vladimir guerrero jr to begin the sixth
here's lewisgale's one-two to guerrero
and he hits a ground ball to first back
can't stop bruce
goes to the bag in time one away nice
play
by bruce so the lucky tim meza
against jay bruce
looped into shallow left center field
that is going to be a base hit
two runs will score a big single for
bruce his
first base hit as a yankee and the
yankees now lead five to two
gary sanchez one for three the one was
another home run his second in as many
games
now swinging a ground ball up the middle
simeon to the left of second on to first
in time to get sanchez and the inning is
over
back to the top of the order for marcus
simeon who's had a very nice afternoon
singled and stole the base in the first
walked and stole the base in the third
and then homert in the fifth gritchik
the lead at third
and the yankees will concede the run up
by three here in the seventh inning
they'll concede on a ground ball there
is a ground ball
the run will come into score as simeon
is thrown out 6-3 on the put out on the
ground ball to short
and it is 5-3 and rowdy teles looking to
get on track
doe for three with a couple of
strikeouts today over seven so far in
the first two games of the season
here is the one-two to teles struck him
out swinging blew it by
now here is simeon and he swings and
lifts a high pop
toward third or shella underneath he
makes the catch ball game over yankees
win
the yankees win